TOR NORBYE: Hello, everyone.
I'm Tor Norbye from
the Android Tools Team.
This is Romain Guy from
the Android Platform Team.
And we're here to introduce
this Kotlin talk, because we
both use and love Kotlin.
And we're super excited that
it's now officially supported
by our teams.
ROMAIN GUY: Yes, so
one of the big reasons
why we decided to adopt
Kotlin was you guys, everybody
here, all the developers
who have been using Kotlin
in the application, who have
been asking about Kotlin.
So we thought,
usually it's Googlers
on stage at Google I/O, and we
decided that this time around,
we would have non-Googlers.
So we have Christina Lee from
Pinterest and Jake Wharton
from Square.
So they're going
to do all the work,
and Tor and I will
just disappear.
Enjoy.
TOR NORBYE: Bye.
JAKE WHARTON: OK, so
hopefully all of you are
were in Hadi presentation
earlier today.
He talked about the language
and the language features
outside of Kotlin, just
the language in general.
And today we're going to go
through examples in Android--
how the language features can
be used to basically clean up
a bunch of sort of rough edges
of how you write Android code.
So the first thing to
start with is here,
we have a boring main activity.
And what's interesting to
note is that this parameter is
actually nullable, so
if your OP process is
starting from scratch,
this is going to be null.
And the way that we've now
represented this in Java
is with nullable annotations,
support annotation.
And what's great
is that, as these
have been being added to
your code and Support Library
code, when you start
writing Kotlin,
the fact that the method
that you're overriding
has that annotation, means
that Kotlin indicates
that it's a nullable type.
So all of the work
that you've been
doing to annotate over
the last few years
is now going to pay off in
Kotlin where the type system
models nullability.
Similarly, an Android
4.1, a lot of work
was done to normalize the
getters and setters on all
the views, and if you saw--
these are traditionally called
beans in the Java programming
language.
And what's nice is that Kotlin
take these and collapses them
into what's called properties.
So in Java you'd refer
to them directly.
But if we rewrite
this in Kotlin,
you'll see that we're referring
to just an alpha property.
And when we're reading from
it, it calls that getter,
and when we're writing to
it, it calls the setter.
So all of that work
that was done again
now pays off in Kotlin.
So, here's some sample
code that illustrates
when you need to perform some
operation over the children
inside of a view group.
View group is very
similar to a collection,
but it doesn't have any of
the niceties of collections,
like being able to
use a foreach loop.
If we rewrite this and Kotlin,
we get a much more declarative
syntax.
The first thing to
note is the range.
Here, we are using
that infix function,
and it actually will--
even though it's
a function, it's
like a intrinsic
in the compiler,
so you still get a forloop that
uses indexes in the bytecode.
And then here you can see
that the child count property
that we're calling, again
comes from the get child
count method, which is in Java.
But we can do a lot
better than this, right?
This isn't that much different.
It's just a little
bit more clean.
How can we make view
group behave more
like other collections?
While you solve the
extension methods,
you can add an extension
method to view group,
which does this iteration.
And then you're calling code
becomes much more like you
would over a normal collection.
The nice thing to note here
is that extension methods
will desugar into a static
method, where the group is just
the first parameter.
An important thing to note is--
so this is a higher
order function
that takes in a function
as its parameter.
This will actually
cause an anonymous class
to be created at the call
site that encapsulates
the code inside the lambda.
So this can become
prohibitively expensive, right,
if we're using all these
higher order functions
and creating all these
anonymous classes.
Deck size goes up.
Method count goes up.
What we can actually
do is mark this
as being an inline function.
So this wasn't
mentioned by Hadi What
it does is it basically
takes the implementation
of this method and inlines
it into the call site.
And so because the
code has been moved,
you no longer have to
create that anonymous class.
And so this method essentially
becomes free to use.
So one thing that
you might have missed
is we actually lost the ability
to know what index of child
we're looking at,
but that's easily
solved with a second extension
method that allows the index
to be passed in.
And again as an
inline function, we
have no additional
overhead here.
So that was for iteration,
iterating of the child views.
But there's a lot
of other things
we can do to view
group to make it
behave a lot more like a
traditional collection.
So for example, if we add a
get method as an extension
function, we can now
pull out child views
as if it was a list or array.
We can refer to them
by index and have
that corresponding
view returned.
Key thing here, again
that Hadi pointed out,
this is an operator
function, so we're
declaring that it has a
special call site syntax.
And that's what all of
these are going to be.
So how about adding
and removing views?
Well, we can add a minus
assign and plus assign,
and so this allows us
to use shorthand syntax
for removing and again adding.
One more will be looking up
to see if a child's already
in, and again the implementation
of these functions--
we're just reusing the
methods that you otherwise
would have been calling,
but getting a better syntax
at the call site which
allows the view to behave
much more like a collection.
And so this wasn't
highlighted in Hadi's talk,
but it kind of looks like
this is magical, right?
When you're looking
at the code at the top
where you're using
these operators,
how do you know
what implementation
of that is actually running?
Well, a cool trick in
IntelliJ and Android Studio
is that if you actually put your
cursor on one of the operators,
you can Command-B into it,
and it will actually take you
to the corresponding function.
So even though you got
the nice call site syntax,
you still have the
visibility into what
the implementation is doing.
And if you want, you can
actually call these methods
as if they are extension methods
not using the operator syntax,
because again, they're
just normal functions.
So extending a type isn't
limited to just methods.
We can also add properties.
So how about adding
the number of children
as a size property,
which is what
a list or array would expose.
Interesting thing
to note here, again,
using string interpolation,
also mentioned in Hadi's talk.
OK this one's a
little more advanced.
But having the foreach
function that we added only
allows us to do that
type of iteration.
Whereas, a list, we have
all these other higher order
functions--
filtering, mapping--
that we can use
that we can no longer
use on view group,
because it doesn't
extend that base type.
What this code does--
what you don't have to really
look into and understand--
is add the ability to create
an iterator of children.
And so now, we get access to
using the traditional foreach
loop.
And if we want, we can use
those higher order extension
functions that
exist on iterable.
So here I am
collecting the height
of all the visible
views, very declarative.
And if they are
inline functions,
you lose you lose
the overhead as well.
So extension functions are
great for encapsulating
repetitive tasks.
So if you're using custom
trace points as an example,
I always forget to
put the end section.
And especially if
you're refactoring
code that has trace
voice in it, it's
very easy to rearrange
which end section is
applied to which begin section.
And it ends up screwing
up the SIS trace output.
What we can do is just go
back and use this trick
over and over again.
We can encapsulate that code
inside of an inline function.
And so, this will perform
the begin and end,
and then it will execute
our lambda in the middle.
But as an inline function,
we don't pay the cost
of allocating anything.
And so now our call site just
becomes trace with the tag,
and then whatever's in
the body is automatically
wrapped in begin and end.
Another nice thing is
that you can actually
return from these
functions, and so
if you're computing
something, we
don't lose the ability
to capture return value.
OK so same tricks
over and over again.
A lot of times when you're
writing the same boilerplate
code, you can get this like
vision where you lose track
of the ability to differentiate
whether something is correct
or a mistake, because
you're so used to seeing it,
you just gloss over.
And so you might
have missed looking
at this, that were
actually missing setting
the transaction to successful.
And so all the code in this
block wouldn't have even ran.
This is another one where we
can just apply the same trick,
write an inline function
that encapsulates
this ceremony around interacting
with a database transaction,
and then our call
site becomes extremely
simple and declarative.
This one is especially
interesting,
because we still have
to refer to the database
inside the transaction lock.
It would be nice if we
somehow could associate
the statements inside the block
with the enclosing transaction,
because we already specified
it on the database.
So it's redundant to say
it over and over again.
One way to accomplish
this would be
to change the lambda
that's being passed
into the function, such
that we inject the database
reference back into it.
And this allows our code
to pass this into the body.
This allows our code to refer
to the it parameter, which
is when there's only a
single argument being
passed to a lambda.
You can just refer to it as it.
This isn't as nice as
it could be though,
because now every statement
that we put inside this lambda
has to have it prefix
in front of it.
So just like we had extension
functions, which add methods
to a type, we can create
extension lambdas,
or as I believe Kotlin calls
it lambdas with receivers.
Well, it's the same
trick where, if we
change the parameter
of the lambda that's
being passed in to
itself via an extension
function of the
database, This means
that the body inside the
lambda is going to execute,
as if it was a method
on SQLite database.
And such, we can call methods
without having to qualify them
with any reference.
So now, our call site only
mentions the database once,
and then we can just
call the methods
for performing inserts,
updates, and deletes,
without having to qualify them
with the database reference.
OK sticking with databases.
Doing inserts like this is not
terrible-- or deletes, I guess,
in this case--
but the problem is
actually the database
that underlies the--
it has to execute this.
It has to parse the
query every single time.
Figure out that it's
syntactically correct,
figure it out where
the question marks
are that it needs to
bind arguments into.
And so if you're running this
over and over and over again,
you're basically wasting
time in the database
for having it to parse your
query every single time.
The way that this is
solved in the SQLite APIs
is by compiling a
statement ahead of time
and then reusing that
over and over again.
And so now, the database
only has to parse this once,
and then it just
kind of remembers,
creates a model of
what the query is.
And then when you
execute it, it only
has to insert the
arguments and execute them.
So this is nice.
We get a performance
win if we're
calling this a bunch of times.
But we actually change this,
such that if we were calling
delete by first name on a
background thread before,
this compile statement
is going to run
whenever this class
is created, which
is usually the main thread.
And so we move database
work onto the main thread.
The way that this is
fixed is with a feature
called delegation, and this
is property delegation.
It's basically allowing
you to supply code
behind a property that can
run whenever it's assigned to
or read from.
So in this case,
what we're doing is
we're delegating the
implementation of this delete
by first name property
and to a built in Kotlin
feature, which is
going to make it lazy.
So lazy takes in
a lambda now, that
only gets called the
first time that you get
the value from this property.
And so what we've
done is now allowed
this to have the same
behavior as the original,
where it was parsed on the
background thread, but now
it only does it once
instead of many times.
There's a lot of examples of
where delegation on properties
can be useful.
Another built in
one is observable,
which allows the
lambda that you supply
to be called every time the
property value is changed.
So I read a new
property to this name,
and the delegate
calls this lambda
with the old value,
the new value.
For properties that
aren't immediately
going to be initialized,
but that you know
will very soon be initialized--
instead of marking
them as nullable,
which requires you to
initialize it immediately
when the class is created--
you can use a delegate that
allows you to sort of defer
setting the value.
And so if you try to read from
this without setting a value,
it's going to
throw an exception.
But if you write to it and then
read from it, totally fine.
So this is perfect for cases
like activities in fragments
where you don't control
the creation of the class,
but there is a method
in the lifecycle that's
very early, where you usually
set up these properties.
And you can write
your own delegate.
Delegate's just a interface
that you can implement.
So we have one which
allows us to bind views.
So it automatically-- if
this is in a view subclass,
it will lazily look up
this view the first time
that you access it.
Another feature of delegation
is class delegation.
So the transitions
framework lacks a base class
that you can extend
from, such that you only
have to override one method.
Won't it be nice if
we somehow could only
override the method
we needed, and then
have something else
that we delegated to
for those empty implementations?
We can do this.
You can create a class--
this is a object class, which
is a singleton and Kotlin, and
it has empty implementations
of all the functions.
And so now on our original
type, what we can say
is that we're implementing
transaction listener,
but we're going to delegate
every call to this singleton
type, except for the
ones that we override.
And what Kotlin will
do is basically just
add the overrides in the
class automatically, call
the delegate for the ones
you haven't overwritten,
and your code that
is overwritten
for the single method will
be used only for that one.
For testing, we
abstract away espresso.
We have these things called
robots, which are just
kind of high level methods
that we can interact with,
instead of putting espresso
in every single test.
And what's great is
that in Kotlin, we
can call this in a very
readable and declarative way,
but again, another
trick you can do
is with these
extension functions
and lambdas with
receivers, is take
that kind of weird looking
constructor initialization
and the apply method, which
doesn't really make sense
in this case, and
turn it into something
that's much like a DSL.
And so you can build
these type-safe DSLs out
of any domain that
you have in your app.
The testing is just one example.
And so finally, sealed
classes got a mention as well.
So these are basically
type hierarchies
that are better close that
other downstream consumers can't
add an implementation of.
A great use of this on Android
is for recycler view payloads.
So let's say you're displaying
tweets, and when you click them
or when you receive data
from the web service,
you want to update the
counts and the icons.
So you can write a sealed class
for each of these events, which
are the objects that will
send to recycler view
as payloads, so that it knows
the only change a number,
or only change an icon.
In here, we're using data
classes again, also mentioned.
And what's great
about this is we
can use a lot of the
language features
to make this really readable
on the consuming side.
We get the nice looping
with the lambda,
then we can use the
when block, which allows
us to do the smart casting.
So for each of
these branches, they
have associated properties
in the data classes.
So each one can now
reference the properties
without having to do the
explicit cast, because the
when expression took care of it.
So we add the other
branches, and we
get this nice readable
payload implementation,
instead of what we have in Java,
which is a bunch of objects
and a bunch of manual casting.
And so hopefully, all these
examples have really resonated.
I mean there's so many
things over and over
that we do in Java that we can
take the features of the Kotlin
programming language
and apply them
to make the code more fun to
read and more fun to write.
And so now, I'm
going to turn it over
to Christina, who will
talk to you about how
you can adopt the language
in your organization.
[APPLAUSE]
[CHEERING]
CHRISTINA LEE: Thanks, Jake.
So hello.
I just want to start out
by saying, we're here.
This is I/O 2017, and we
have a session about Kotlin.
A lot of people who made that
happen, they're in the room.
Both the Googlers and the
people from JetBrains.
I know I appreciate it.
Can we give them a
round of applause?
[APPLAUSE]
All right.
So it's been a journey--
not as long as it
could have been.
It's been pretty
swift, actually,
but it's been a journey.
A lot of us have been out
there talking to people
and evangelizing Kotlin.
And at first, there were
some objections like, hey,
this language isn't finalized.
Are you sure we should
use that in production?
But as time went
on, that was solved.
We now have our 1.0,
and we've had a lot
of great releases since then.
But I can guarantee
that anybody who's
talked to anyone about
Kotlin has always fielded
exactly the same question.
And that was, so what does
Google think about this?
And this is great, because of
course, now I can stand here
and say, solved problem.
This is my last slide, goodbye.
But it's not actually that
easy, because of course, this
is like one of those situations
where your friend says hey,
do you want to run?
And you're on the couch watching
TV and say, sorry, don't
have running shoes.
Shucks.
And then they say,
it's OK we can just
do push-ups You don't
need equipment for that.
We've taken away that
first layer of excuse.
It's the pushback that
we got most often,
and now we don't
have that pushback.
We have a stance.
We know where we stand, but
that doesn't mean that there's
no work to be done.
Now, there's quite a
bit of work actually.
And so I'm going to talk to
you about how to do that.
A lot of the experience
will come from my mistakes
but also from a lot of
you in the community
that I've been talking to.
So I like to break this
down into three steps.
The first one and
the easiest is you.
You control what you say.
You control how you say
it and who you say it to.
That control, it gives
you a lot of power.
The second one is management.
This is often the
elephant in the room,
but we have some strategies to
make it easier to talk to them.
And last, and I leave
at last on purpose,
because I truly believe
it's the hardest part,
is getting buy-in from your
team and creating an environment
where when you
introduce a new tool,
everybody that you work with
can be as successful and as
productive as you are with it.
So let's start with you.
I have this quote here
that has absolutely nothing
to do with tech.
It's a very grandiose
quote, and the essence of it
is that the only
thing that's ever
created change in the world
is a small group of people
who have cared deeply.
And I know that
we're not usually
here to change the world.
We're here to change code bases.
But the reason I include
this is because the language
of influence is
applicable to all of us.
This happens in industries
all around the world,
and we don't get
to escape from it.
I know that a lot of people
in this room are saying,
but wait, I'm an introvert.
I don't know if I can go
on stage and do a dance
and shout, go Kotlin.
And I'm not asking
you to do that.
There are a lot of ways
for you to show enthusiasm
and to be passionate.
You can tweet about it.
You can send a slack message
to your best friend, an email,
an SMS, an MMS if we
want to go back 10 years.
It doesn't really matter.
There are a lot of ways that you
can communicate that you care,
but the important thing is
that you do communicate.
Because of course, if
you're sitting here
waiting for the
people in your offers
to be struck by a thunderbolt
and suddenly understand
the awe-inspiring nature
of nullable types,
you're probably going
to be left waiting.
So be enthusiastic and
share that enthusiasm
with other people, no
matter what that looks like.
But the corollary to that
is that the easy part
is being enthusiastic.
It's a great language.
It's not that hard to
get excited about it,
but you also need
to sign up for what
comes with that, which is that
people will have questions.
If you have a build
system completely
based on the Java
programming language
and you introduce
a new tool to it,
there's a good chance
that it might hiccup,
that something might not
go exactly as planned.
And you need to be there to
make sure that you can fix that,
because if you care enough
to introduce a new tool,
you also need to care enough
to be a steward for it.
That's all I'm going to say
about you, because again, it's
the part that you control.
It's the easy part, right?
Just get excited.
It works.
Now, management.
Management is the
elephant in the room.
I started by saying,
hey, the number one
question I got was what
is Google's stance.
But of course, the
number two thing
that I talked about with
the community was I'm sold.
I love it, but I can't convince
the people in my company
that I should be
allowed to adopt Kotlin.
So let's talk about that.
I have been on stage,
and I've said, hey,
there's this magic
argument you can use.
You just walk into
someone's office,
and then you say,
give me this language
and I'll give you in NPE or
a relatively NPE free app.
I say relatively, because where
there's a will, there's a way.
But this is a great argument--
the more I talked about it
with you in the
community though,
the more I realized that
it boils down to something
much more fundamental.
And that is that Kotlin
and languages like it,
they help us offload
things that we're not
that good at onto our computer.
And we already do this a lot.
The way I know that we do this
is that we all collectively
freak out anytime
our computer breaks.
I know I do it.
I've seen other people
do it, and that's
because computers
are fundamentally
a huge part of our life.
They're really, really good
at doing the things that
were really, really bad
at, and that frees us up
to do some of the more creative
thinking, the architecting,
the making sure that it
works for your coworkers.
All of these more creative
and critical thinking tasks
are things that we
get to focus on more.
And when talking
to management, this
is something that
they understand.
They're going to
have questions, yes.
But if you move this
conversation onto the pain of,
hey, I have this
tool, and I want
to use it more effectively.
People understand
what that means.
So of course, one example
of this from Jake,
is just saying that types
are a form of testing,
and whether you fully
agree with this or not,
the underlying sentiment is that
we are catching errors sooner.
And we're doing it without
having to keep it all logged
into our head.
And since we don't
have to juggle
the 10 different places
that something could
be null or mutating or any
of those other variables,
it gives us more time to
think about other stuff.
Sorry.
This is my favorite
photo in this slide deck.
The point here is that people
and companies are risk averse,
and the reason
they're risk averse
is because someone's
job out there
is to make sure that your
company doesn't burn down.
And that's a very
noble profession,
and I appreciate
that they're there.
So they have to
keep us in check,
and that means that when
you're communicating to them,
you can, by all means,
feel free to say
there's this thing called VAL.
And then you changed one
letter, and it's a VAR,
and it's magical.
And it's revolutionary, and
you're going to love it.
And if your manager
is really cool,
maybe they'll understand that.
But for a lot of
people, that's not
going to be a really
persuasive argument,
and it's because even
if they understand
that from a technical level,
it doesn't have resonance.
So talk to people in a
language that they understand.
Talk to them, not
about the methodology,
but about the end
goal, which is to say,
instead of saying there's
typed nullability,
say I can provide
you an app that's
more stable for our users.
It'll crash less.
The users will be happier.
Or if your
management, like mine,
values moving fast,
say, hey, I have a tool,
and if you allow me to use it,
I can make more reusable code.
And I can iterate faster,
and we can get more product
out the door.
Again, feel free to talk
to them about Kotlin.
I am never going to discourage
anybody from doing that.
But also step out of your
shoes and into theirs,
and talk to them
at a business level
about what they care about.
OK.
Last and hardest, the team.
Now, this is a really
good place for me
to add the caveat that
I'm here, because I've
made some mistakes.
And I want to share them
with you, so that you don't
have to make the same ones.
I'm sure people will
find new ones to make,
but at least they won't be mine.
So to start, define success.
Know what that
looks like for you.
And I say this, because
I was out on the grass
when we announced that Kotlin
was going to be supported.
And I heard a lot of
you saying, hey, cool.
So does this mean that I can
just convert my whole code
base to Kotlin?
And I said, oh yes.
I mean if that works at
your office, by all means.
But what I've learned
in my Kotlin adoption,
was that if you do
that, you're going
to have to put up with
grumbling for months to come.
And the reason for
that is that teams--
they're made of diverse people,
and diverse people almost never
agree unanimously.
Which is to say, if you're
in a startup with two people,
maybe you can go to
lunch and agree on this
and push the code that day.
But if you're in
a bigger company
and you have 30 or
40 doves on a team,
getting them all into a single
room and agreeing on something
is going to be time consuming.
And it's going to take effort.
And so when defining
success, I would, again,
encourage you to
focus on the outcome.
If you want to
stand there and say
Kotlin is the best
language, you can,
but I guarantee you someone
will stand up and want
to argue with you.
Because it's fun to argue, and
developers love to do that.
I'm one of them.
I know.
So what I would encourage
you to do instead is say,
we want a stable code base.
We want to hit this metric for
number of crash free sessions.
We want to be able
to iterate faster.
Any of these things, it's
easy for people to agree on.
They're not
controversial statements.
And if you start with the
common goal with your team,
then when you say,
hey, there's this tool.
It will get us to this
goal in XYZ steps.
It's a lot easier to
have that conversation.
You don't have to
start a flame war.
You can sit there, and
you can dissect pieces
and have productive
conversations
on smaller chunks.
Now, part of this is also
getting stakeholders on board,
which is something I mildly
did but also mildly didn't.
So the importance of
this is that if you're
like me and you're a developer
and not in the management
chain, it means that
if anything goes wrong
after you adopt a new
tool like Kotlin, someone
above you in that
chain it's going
to be on the hook for it,
which is great for me,
but less so for them.
So there's also this dynamic too
that consists of you standing
here saying, hey, this
is a great language,
and then someone going
off and saying, hey,
have you heard
about this language?
Christina says it
was great, but I just
wanted to hear your opinion.
And for both of
these reasons, you
want to make sure that the
culture setters in your company
are on board, both because
if something happens,
you want them to have
your back and to say
this is the right path for us.
It's worth it to
push through this.
Let's just fix it.
And also because if the
culture setters in your company
aren't on board, you're going
to have a lot of dissent.
And I know we can
get complacent,
because the interop is so good
between the Java programming
language and Kotlin, but
it's really not a great place
for your team to be.
Oh there we go.
Now, also find someone who
reviews your code like this,
exactly like this.
I do this for my team.
I've been known to
skip around my desk.
It's happened.
Ask any of my coworkers
in the audience.
And you should find
someone in your company
who feels exactly the same way.
And the reason I say
that is that again,
in talking to the audience
and to members of the Kotlin
community, a lot of you had
said I just snuck Kotlin in.
And it was great,
and nobody knew.
Now, one, do you
all still have jobs?
Like how is that
working for you?
I mean, we need to talk.
I don't know about these
rogue commits that are just
coming up left and right.
I appreciate the spirit though.
And two, that means
that you shoulder
all that work on yourself.
And I don't know about you,
but I'm already pretty busy.
I've got a lot of e-mails
to write during the day.
And so if you can find people
who feel like you to work with,
that's going to make
your job less hard.
And the other reason
this is important,
is that this language,
although it's
been around for
several years now,
is just hitting
widespread adoption.
And what that means
from your perspective,
is that we don't have 20
years worth of code styles
to fall back on and best
practices and books and all
of the things of that nature.
And that means, that
when you introduce Kotlin
into your code base, you get
to have those conversations.
And as a developer,
that's fun, but it's also
time away from your work.
And what does this look like?
It looks like you adding
Kotlin to your code
and having almost two ways to do
almost exactly the same thing.
We need to standardize
our code base, ergo,
what is my company's position?
Which one do we default to?
I've also heard
from the Trello team
that they have a
lot of conversations
about what it means to be null
when we have typed nullability.
This wasn't a
conversation that we
had to have before,
because by default,
most things were nullable.
But now that we control that in
a much more concise way, what
does it mean?
You need to decide.
Is it valid for me to
make this thing nullable,
or is that just completely
illogical for the data
structure that I'm building?
These conversations,
they need to be had.
And while you can have
them with your whole team,
you can dive in and
say we're all on board.
It's going to get noisy.
There's a lot of thrashing
involved in deciding
what your future looks like.
And so this is why I would
recommend finding a nucleus
and working with them.
It should go without
saying that I also
hope that you document all of
this, because at some point
you should bring
everybody else on board.
And of course, I'm not
saying not to get opinions.
I'm just saying that if you
try to adopt by consensus,
it might not move you along
as fast as you would otherwise
hope.
Now, I also want to
point out something--
this is from Dan Lew's blog--
about what you're expecting
from your coworkers
when you ask them to
adopt a new language.
And that's that
you're asking them
to go from a place of expertise
to a place where they're new
again.
And yes, JetBrains has done
everything in their power
to make this seamless.
The IDE support is great.
You can copy and
paste for convert.
You can right-click convert.
You can have hints in your IDE.
You have the
compile time errors.
They have smoothed
the way for you,
and it is easy, way easier than
anything else I've adopted.
But that doesn't mean
that there's no work.
And so people when they use
the Java programming language,
are often coming from a place
of having used it for years.
And that means that they know
all of the little tricks.
They've read all
the interview books.
They've read the blog
posts and the puzzlers
and all of those things.
And so they know those
tiny little edge cases,
just from having been in
the environment for ages.
And when you come
to a new language,
you don't necessarily bring
that knowledge with you.
A lot of it is still
applicable, but you also
have to expect that
there are going
to be some times where you
haven't found all of the edge
cases.
And you're going to
be burned by them.
And so if you're asking
that of your teammates,
you need to make sure that
onboarding is a first class
citizen.
And I know this
isn't that exciting.
We're all developers.
We want to code.
Who wants documentation anyways?
But it really, really
is important if you
want Kotlin to be
successful in your company.
And that's because you can say,
oh, well everybody on my team
right now, they know Kotlin,
so we don't need to onboard.
But what about when
your interns come in?
Or when you hire someone
new in two months?
We are not at a
point in the industry
right now where we can
expect that everybody
walking through our interview
pipeline knows this language.
And so if you throw
them in the deep end
without any flotation
device, that's on you,
and you should expect them
to feel lost and overwhelmed.
So make onboarding a
first class citizen.
Think about it early.
This probably
means that you have
to change what you're doing
in the first two weeks
that your employees arrive.
You'll have to update
documentation, code examples,
make sure that they
have the tools they need
to run this new
language, and probably do
some mentorship as they learn
the language on the job.
Do that work.
It's really important, and I
know, because I put it off.
So don't be like me.
Get it out of the way
early, so that you
don't have a bifurcated team.
Again, interop, it has
all of the merits, right?
It's great.
But it can also make us
lazy, because we can say,
they don't need to use Kotlin.
They can use Java.
But Kotlin, it's here to stay,
and we want people to enjoy it.
And we want them to partake.
So just saying, you
don't need Kotlin.
You can use Java--
it's not the best route.
Really.
Now, my only last
remaining point, show up.
Be there for the work
that needs to take place.
That documentation
updating, that advocacy,
we all know Jake's white
paper from several years ago.
That didn't just
poof into existence.
He sat down, and he wrote it.
And I know at my company,
we've had those moments too.
We've done the behind
the scenes work that
has made the adoption during the
workday much more successful,
and it's not glamorous.
I know.
But if you want Kotlin to be
successful in your company,
it's necessary.
And now that I've
bummed you all out
and told you how hard
this is all going to be,
I just want to remind
you where we are.
We have official
support for Kotlin,
and that's a great place to be.
So yes, there's
work involved in it.
I know, and it's not
sexy work either.
It's not as fun
as writing Kotlin.
But it's worth it.
We have the chance to
use an amazing language,
so let's put to work
in to make it happen.
Now, I know a lot of you, after
the keynote, were asking, hey,
I'm interested.
I'm solid.
How do I get started?
Well, here are a few resources.
Predictably, I have links to
both the Android documentation
and the JetBrains documentation.
On that JetBrains
site, you'll find
koans, which are ways to
go through coding exercises
and explore the
language incrementally,
as well as a standard
documentation
and a [INAUDIBLE].
And then obviously, there's a
book that came out about Kotlin
recently, and I would
encourage you to read it.
That's all I have for you today.
There's no time for questions,
but we'll be outside
after this presentation.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
SPEAKER: Thank you for
joining this session.
[MUSIC PLAYING]